Adam Lambert shares an update on Ke$ha  from what I know she's doing really well  the American Idol alum posted this photo  with Kesha last week showing his support  for the singer who's been embroiled in a  legal dispute with Sony and music  producer dr. Luke Lambert opened up to  et on Thursday how's she holding up  i what i know she's doing really well i  saw her briefly in nashville it was  really nice to see her we have we go way  back from art when we've both first got  signed so it was really nice to see her  lambert isn't the only celeb who's  rushed to Kesha's defense adele used her  acceptance speech at the BRIT Awards  last month to publicly show her support  while taylor swift donated two hundred  and fifty thousand dollars to the pop  star